le théâtre de verdure de beaune se
prépare à retrouver une seconde jeunesse
dans le cadre de la mission stéphane
stéphane bern pour la sauvegarde du
patrimoine en péril
trois cent mille euros seront versés à
la ville pour sa restauration visite de
chantier avec amélie doué et bamba k
alors est-ce que c'était pour déclencher
la douche en tous les cas c'est tout à
fait mais dont je pense profonde avec
déjà un confort moderne
bienvenue aux bains douches ou tout du
moins ce qu'il reste de la salle de bain
commune des beaunois reconstruite en
1813 vous voyez à l'intérieur ce qui est
sympa c'est que on a retrouvé les
mosaïques d'origine fermons magnifique
installé dans un jardin public au pied
des remparts l'édifice inspiré des
anciens thermes méditerranéen est resté
en activité jusque dans les années 60
avant de devenir un théâtre de verdure
le bâtiment n'est pas en très bon état
puisque nous sommes dans les douves des
remparts de bonnes et c'est théâtre de
verdure avait été construit sans
fondations avec un défaut de charpente
très important qui aujourd'hui fait que
le bâtiment en fait pousse des deux
côtés et donc on a une toiture qui
s'effondre et un bâtiment qui a vraiment
besoin qu'on réintervient pour pouvoir
le consolider grâce aux trois cent mille
euros d aides accordées sur les 800000
nécessaire les travaux vont démarrer au
printemps prochain viendra ensuite la
réhabilitation des bains en loge avant
de rendre ce théâtre emblématique au
public ont choisi en fonction
principalement de quatre critères
l'intérêt patrimoniale du site l'état de
périls du site la maturité du projet de
restauration est enfin là le projet
culturel là et l'animation du site et en
l'occurrence sur ce théâtre de verdure
ce quatrième critère qui est rarement
bien emplie a été prépondérant un joli
cadeau de noël dont ont pu également
bénéficier la ferme de danse l'un dans
la nièvre où le vieux pont de pont sur
yonne